this is gonna be fun
swung a little wide there
well aren't we a tall glass of water me
I'm more of a Hawaiian God
I'm guessing you don't fight much
outside of your car now do you oh wow I
don't need four wheels to kick your ass
any chance we get this back in the cars
how about a little kill music
[Music]
this is a misunderstanding I've been
getting shot at ever since I can
remember
fourth habit I guess sounds like you
have trust issues yeah you're not wrong
nice pipes dude I have to say that high
note
that's perfect a word can I go I got
somewhere to be I thought you said you
were coming to the show of course I am
just
can I leave after the show
well in that case the night is opening
night
foreign